back it up  it's over  Pals no no no get it done and on the  Spin and the reverse the Slam by his eye  I know you didn't like it  six game winning streak for the pals  I don't think they're yeah Jose and  Chris Paul at the end of the game  and he got into Chris Ball no but this  came from the last two possessions  though right but it came from the last  two possessions with Larry Nam shooting  layup when the game is over and then  Zion doing a 360 when the game is over  yeah but this is how rivalry start  though right this is how they start it's  unfortunate though it's going to be over  before Christmas the season series  [Applause]  so Zion gets it on the 360. to close it  out